[Music]
in 2015 antonio geum takes another stock
photo just like he has thousands of
times before two years later several
people use this image to make jokes but
it's soon lost in the sea of internet
memes then on August 19th Twitter user
n1 m16 one makes this mean joking about
young people's affinity for socialism
the post goes a little Twitter viral and
suddenly the collective hive mind of the
Internet has decided that it's found its
new favorite meme for now why do memes
capture our attention what causes a
memes meteoric rise to the top of
internet culture at a given moment I've
got a few ideas thank you to Squarespace
for sponsoring this video
memes have been growing in notoriety in
recent years I've noticed more and more
people even those who aren't deep into
internet culture talked about a meme
they saw when most people use the word
meme today they're referring to an image
macro these internet memes usually have
two parts an image that serves as a
caricature or symbolic representation
and a recognizable layout of text used
to make a joke in conjunction with the
image but to understand a successful
internet meme we'll need to dig a little
deeper into where the word meme comes
from the meme is the unit of cultural
inheritance it's anything that behaves
like a gene in human culture this is
Richard Dawkins who coined the term meme
in his 1976 book The Selfish Gene though
he coined the term before internet memes
existed the name fits because Dawkins
idea of meme is an almost perfect
description of how an internet meme
works there's a cultural survival of the
fittest process that helps create and
spread successful means the equivalent
of the act of reproduction the genetic
level would be the act of copying
an idea from one brain to another the
process selects for the appeal of the
meme and the ability of the image and
joke format to be reapplied to many
topics memes are chosen by a subculture
by a larger group because they resonate
but what causes this resonance let's use
the recently popular distracted
boyfriend meme as our guiding example a
successful meme expresses a certain idea
or concept more quickly than that idea
could be articulated if you look at the
page for this stock photo on
Shutterstock you'll see the full title
of disloyal man walking with his
girlfriend and looking amazed at another
seductive girl it takes a lot of words
to describe this scenario but when you
look at this image you know immediately
what's going on the characters have a
past there's a future fallout from this
moment but more importantly there is a
core feeling that is time consuming to
lay out in words but that is immediately
evident when viewing the photo in this
way it behaves as an archetypal image an
archetype is a deeply felt instinctual
pre idea form embedded in the collective
unconscious and while the archetype
itself cannot be defined or expressed
explicitly we can recognize it when it's
represented in an archetypal image the
archetype embedded in this image is a
complex scenario recognised by all of us
easily it can be described by the phrase
the grass is always greener on the other
side of the fence but even using that
phrase is resorting to another
archetypal image to represent this
scenario so a good meme succeeds because
it taps into the past experiences of the
collective and as it spreads it becomes
part of the collective symbolism for
those experiences that's Stefan Haven a
shutterstock developer I spoke with who
works on an image editing tool that lets
people quickly create their own versions
of the meme
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is why stock images tend to make
great memes images that end up being
used in successful memes often have
characters whose expressions are
exaggerated they appear as caricatures
for the emotions or feelings they are
expressing those exaggerated elements
make the meme stronger because its
symbolism is more easily detected by
more people and the exaggerated effect
is funny we tend to like it for the same
reason we like cartoons this isn't to
suggest that a meme has to be gotten by
everyone an individual meme can appeal
to a small group sometimes they have
appealed because only a small group
recognized the symbolism of a meme memes
often act as a sort of in-group
identifier like inside jokes and TV show
references a meme is a way of
discovering who we have a common base of
understanding with and they're short but
intense life spans make them sign posts
for eras of internet culture the perfect
meme often seems to be one where the
image element is broad enough that many
people get the symbolism while the joke
conveyed through text has a very narrow
appeal let's examine the modes in which
a meme can interact with culture the
first mode is how the meme interacts
with the viewer upon first exposure with
the distracted boyfriend meme the first
time you see it you find it funny
because of the way someone modified it
to make a joke but also because the
photo itself is funny in the second mode
a memes ability to be remixed is crucial
this is the mode where the meme gains
the most traction a good meme has a
formula that makes the application of
the core archetype to many different
scenarios easy in this mode most of the
humor is generated from seeing all the
ways in which people can use the meat in
the third mode humor and freshness are
generated by the subversion of the
established formula of the meme now that
most of the possible applications are
exhausted people begin to modify the
original nature of the meme and use it
to express ideas that are similar or
even the inverse
of the original archetype ultimately a
meme can enter the cultural lexicon it
can become a tool or a sort of shorthand
that we might use to refer to the
archetype at the core of the mean most
memes won't operate within all these
modes but successful memes that stick
around usually operate well in multiple
modes types of memes existed long before
the internet but the Internet has had a
big influence on memes and the way we
look at them first by increasing the
number of connections and points of
communication it speeds up the evolution
of memes second the internet makes this
evolutionary process much more visible
than it's been in the past before the
internet tracking little-known non image
memes out and culture would have been
extremely difficult although for the
most part memes remain an enigma dick
and difficult to track but maybe it's
worth the effort I think we
underestimate the importance of what a
meme represents the individual meme
might seem trivial but tracking trends
across many memes might reveal the
deeply felt ideas in Internet culture
that they represent maybe we can learn
something about ourselves by tracking
which memes survive at the very least
become an evolutionary force that helps
shape our culture and share a meme
[Music]
building and running a website doesn't
have to be a pain with squarespace's
all-in-one platform and 24/7 support you
can stop fiddling with annoying code and
other details and focus on bringing your
ideas to life although if you do want to
get under the hood and customize things
you can do that too
Squarespace gives you some awesome
templates as a starting place but the
flexible platform lets you customize it
to fit whatever needs you have make your
next move with Squarespace Squarespace
is a one-stop shop to grab a unique
domain and build a beautiful website for
whatever project or idea
you have start your free trial today at
squarespace.com and enter offer code
thomas flight to get 10% off your first
purchase thank you so much to those who
support me on patreon if you appreciate
my content and want to consider
supporting me I hugely appreciate it
it'll help me continue to make these
videos for a long time to come
I'm Thomas flight thank you so much for
watching and subscribing